[Musique]
à thiruvananthapuram capitale du kerala
la police a dû recourir aux gaz
lacrymogènes et aux canons d'eau pour
disperser la foule de manifestants n 2
ces émeutes font suite à la décision de
la cour suprême de permettre aux femmes
d'accéder au temple
des médias locaux ont rapporté que deux
femmes
escorté par des policiers sans entrer
dans le temple de sabarimala au lieu du
culte hindu east une victoire pour cette
militante des droits des femmes et à
l'entrée des femmes au temple et
historique pour nous et pour l'égalité
malgré l'opposition
les femmes sont entrées au temple les
manifestations hanté chou et le kerala y
depuis quelques temps au coeur
d'affrontements entre les indie ou
traditionalistes favorable au maintien
de l'interdiction et les partisans de la
décision de la cour suprême
nous avons manifesté depuis plusieurs
mois de façon pacifique à travers des
rituels sacrés des prières mais le
gouvernement et le premier ministre du
kerala nous ont provoqués en amenant ces
deux femmes au temple en guise de
soutien la décision rendue par la cour
suprême
des milliers de femmes en former une
chaîne humaine à klémurs des femmes la
décision est appuyée par le gouvernement
du kerala
mais le premier ministre de l'inde s'y
opposent en inde tout le monde bénéficie
des mêmes droits des certains temples
sont également interdits aux hommes
concernant la décision de la cour
suprême il n'y a pas lieu de l'attribuer
à un parti politique il faut lire les
recommandations de la cour
l'état du kerala compte plus de 33
millions d'habitants et plus de la
moitié et hindu la décision de la cour
suprême coincide avec les fêtes
religieuses annuel ici as milk hayat
radio canada montréal